lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
pensar en las formas posibles en las que
se desplazan las curvas de oferta y las
curvas de demanda y por eso tenemos ocho
versiones de la misma gráfica cada
gráfica muestra la situación actual para
cierta región en el mercado de helado es
importante escribir el título de cada
gráfica especialmente si están
realizando un examen en el eje vertical
tenemos el precio representado con la
letra p y en el eje horizontal tenemos
la cantidad representada por la letra q
aquí tenemos la curva de la oferta con
pendiente positiva que se llama s1 este
es nuestro punto inicial y acá tenemos
la curva de demanda con pendiente
negativa que llamamos de 1 y en el punto
donde se intersectan tenemos nuestro
precio de equilibrio de 1 y la cantidad
de equilibrio que uno recuerden que si
están resolviendo un examen tienen que
etiquetar cada uno de los elementos de
la gráfica incluyendo p uno y uno con
sus respectivas líneas punteadas para
indicar qué son los puntos de
intersección de las dos curvas teniendo
esto en mente veamos qué sucede con el
precio
equilibrio y la cantidad de equilibrio
cuando ocurren diferentes cambios en las
curvas de oferta y demanda imaginemos
que en este primer escenario aparece en
el mercado un gran productor de helado
esta es la situación en la que la oferta
aumenta una forma de pensar en esto es
dándonos cuenta de que para cualquier
precio dado habrá una mayor cantidad de
gente dispuesta a ofrecer más helado así
que aquí tenemos una nueva curva de
oferta a la derecha y le llamaremos s2
se desplaza a la derecha y hacia abajo
que ocurre ahora con el precio de
equilibrio y la cantidad de equilibrio
si dibujamos una línea punteada aquí
veremos que el precio de equilibrio 2 es
menor y la cantidad de equilibrio 2 es
mayor
claro suponiendo que tenemos la misma
curva de demanda qué es lo que vemos
aquí la demanda no se vio afectada en
este caso el precio disminuye y la
cantidad aumenta veamos otro escenario
en donde ocurre lo contrario ahora la
oferta disminuye qué va a ocurrir en la
gráfica en especial al precio de
equilibrio ya la cantidad de equilibrio
en este caso para un precio dado
una menor cantidad de gente que esté
dispuesta a ofrecer menos helado por lo
que la curva se moverá hacia la
izquierda y le llamaremos s2 ahora cuál
es el punto de equilibrio está aquí el
nuevo precio de equilibrio es mayor y la
nueva cantidad de equilibrio es menor lo
escribimos noten que lo que ocurre en
estos dos escenarios es bastante obvio
cuando un oferente entra al mercado la
cantidad va a aumentar habrá más
competencia y el precio va a disminuir
en este otro escenario cuando un
oferente se va pensemos que una
heladería cierra la cantidad va a
disminuir y el precio va a aumentar el
precio de equilibrio va a aumentar ahora
hagamos lo mismo con la curva de demanda
imaginemos un escenario en donde aumenta
la demanda que va a ocurrir en este
escenario quizá la demanda aumenta
porque es verano y hace mucho calor y la
gente lo come para refrescarse por lo
que para este precio las personas piden
una mayor cantidad la curva de demanda
se va a mover hacia la derecha y arriba
y me llamamos de dos aquí está nuestro
nuevo punto de equilibrio
vean lo que acaba de ocurrir q 2 es
nuestra nueva cantidad de equilibrio y
por acá tenemos el nuevo precio de
equilibrio en este caso donde tenemos un
aumento en la demanda tanto el precio
como la cantidad van a aumentar
suponiendo que tenemos esta misma curva
de oferta con pendiente positiva eso
tiene sentido ya que más personas
quieren comprar helado y no ha cambiado
la dinámica de la curva de oferta por lo
que nos vamos a mover sobre la curva de
la oferta arriba a la derecha
así que aumenta el precio y la cantidad
en este cuarto escenario la demanda va a
disminuir imaginemos que hay un estudio
que dice que el helado es dañino para la
salud por lo que para cierto precio las
personas van a demandar menos helado así
que la curva de demanda se moverá hacia
abajo y a la izquierda
esta es la curva de 2 veamos dónde están
nuestra nueva cantidad de equilibrio y
nuevo precio de equilibrio aquí está el
precio 2 y la cantidad 2 noten que tanto
la cantidad como el precio disminuyen ya
que nadie quiere comprar helado nos
vemos el otro vídeo